hi I'm Bob NOC bar I gave a talk today
on building an interactive game based on
the Jeopardy game using Wolfram language
using various features of the dynamic
capabilities of the language I talked
about the process of getting data from
the web through an API designing a model
initially for the game building it piece
by piece it early improving it by adding
color and improving the fonts adding
sound and in the end we actually played
the game with two real contestants and
we use questions about the Wolfram
language some of the new features and
different parts and I think everybody
had a great time I had a lot of fun
building it and using it with teenagers
which was the original purpose and we'll
see where it goes from there
thank you ok uh welcome everybody I'm
going to talk about a game that I built
with Wolfram language based on the
Jeopardy TV show game it came up in the
context of a bunch of teenagers at a
retreat and we wanted to have an
activity on Saturday afternoon and so
they said let's play jeopardy ok we can
use topics from the theme of the retreat
and stuff like that and I said cool and
somebody pointed me to a PowerPoint
template and I said wait a minute no I
can make something a whole lot better
because I know how to use buttons and
things like that and Wolfram language so
this is you know the result of about a
weekend's worth of work to put it
together and I will go through the
process that I use to build a game to
refine the game and at the end I'm
hoping that I have enough time we can
actually play the game with you guys
ok so you all know about jeopardy most
of you do right the TV game where there
are some contestants and there's a board
with dollar amounts on it that they get
to pick and behind it is an answer and
they have to provide the question for
that answer and if they get it right
they get that score added that amount
added to their
SCOR if not somebody else gets to try
the ant to answer it and at the end of
the game when all the questions or the
clues have been answered then we see who
wins there are a lot of derivative games
out there you know as I said PowerPoint
templates board games and there are even
some do-it-yourself stuff to do it a lot
of them based on PowerPoint and I you
know wanted to do something that would
be more fun and more engaging so we had
a number of constraints some of them
soft some of them imposed by the
organizers of the retreat some imposed
by me so you know we chose the
categories in advance and the we had to
handle up to you know in the end I've
done this like three or four times now
eight different teams
traditionally jeopardy just has three
contestants so we had to keep it
flexible that way I wanted to keep the
scoring automatic so there'd be no
arguments about who won they didn't want
a building timer because it'd be too
distracting for teenagers perfectly you
know respectable requirement for the
design specification we wanted to be
able to play both jeopardy and double
jeopardy because in the second game on
the TV show all the amounts are doubled
and then they call that double jeopardy
but we didn't want to have to get into
the final Jeopardy question which where
they put one question up and everybody
you know the contestants get to wager
what they've won so far on that last
question and basically a double or
nothing type of situation we didn't want
to do that we wanted to use real
jeopardy questions and clues clues and
answers and it turns out we can do that
on the web and it was a really cool part
of this the clues and answers for the
game in the end really need to be depend
on the settings so you know do I want to
use clues from real jeopardy games do I
want to use them in a classroom setting
for let's say history or geography or
biology so it needs to I wanted it to be
flexible for that and I'm glad I
did because you know I've used it in in
three or four different settings and
with different types of questions and
the teacher would give me you know a
spreadsheet with questions in it and I'd
have to you know get them in and make it
work the same way
as pulling the questions for the
Jeopardy questions from the website
let's see we didn't do the Daily Double
feature in the game you know it's
sometimes when the contestants would
pick you know geography for five hundred
it would flash up Daily Double and so
they would actually have the chance of
winning a thousand dollars instead of
just five hundred if they got that one
right that was an extra layer of
complexity that we didn't want to deal
with and I didn't have to try to program
it and I also didn't want the players to
be distracted by the operation of the
game when I've seen it run before
through PowerPoint there's all the
shuffling back and forth and things get
out of sync and I wanted to avoid that
one to be a smoother experience easier
on the organizers of the event and
certainly easier on the contestants so
the way I went about doing this I wanted
to start with real data
I find that starting with real example
data makes it much easier to figure out
what you can do what you can't do and to
design what you're trying to build in
the end the the game board had a
category include area and it had a team
area for keeping score let's see we had
to understand the gameplay and be able
to design a a process what I you know
it's essentially an event loop which is
small on a finite state automaton those
of you from computer science would know
what that is but it's a way of
controlling the movement from one state
to the next during the game from
question selection time to question
answer time to awarding the score time
and then going back and repeat they're
they're used a lot when you have that
sort of situation that you need to
control very carefully and then there's
always the test and tweak and test and
tweak and debug cycle that you go
through at the end and then finally we
get to play
okay so the basics for the API there is
a service called J service out on the
web and it is a REST API and you you
basically send a URL with a query in it
requesting information from the service
and we can ask for information on clues
we can ask for a random clue along with
its answer and the number of dollars the
value of that clue we can get them we
can get categories so that you know you
can choose all the build a database
basically of all the categories
available in the game and they get
questions by category there appears to
be a service where you can indicate that
a given clue is invalid in their
database but I've never looked into that
so that's what we were working with the
the REST API is described in Wikipedia
and there's a nice tutorial here on how
to use it
this API was well documented that
single-page there let me do everything
that I needed to do I've seen some other
api's where there's like no
documentation and it's impossible to
drive to figure out not only how to get
the data out that you want but what data
are available and a lot of times you
know you need to explore to find out
what what you can do so on this API we
got Clues we've got categories and we
can have random clues so just for a
couple of examples let me make sure that
I've got everything evaluated okay so we
can the traditional way of sending a
request for an API and Wolfram language
is to use the import command and you
just give it the URL as a string and you
tell it the format you want back in this
case JSON and it converts the JSON into
a set of nested rules which are very
easy to work with the more modern way to
do this now is
with URL execute and we can give it the
same query here in the import we have to
tell it that we're asking if you know
one random query so we're telling it the
counts to be one with URL execute we can
put these in a little more Wolfram
language like way as a list of rules
with property name and then the value
for it out here along with any other
properties we need to specify such as
authentication and things like that
for the this the the API but you can see
we're getting the same information back
and we can also ask for categories so
when I ask for it that way we get back
the category ID the title of the
category and how many clues were
available in that the Jeopardy game has
reused clues or categories and so
sometimes you might find 10 clues or 15
clues in a given category okay now there
are two different ways I mentioned that
you can get make a request to get the
clues with the questions the answer is
the values in the name of the category
that they're in the first way is to make
a a category request and here we can see
that it comes back first of all with a
list of rules in it and a few other
pieces of information and making a
prefix tree here you can see that we get
clues and ID the title of the category
and the number of clues in it and then
under the clues we've got all five clues
here with their value the question the
answer the date that it was aired on TV
the category ID to which it belongs in
the game ID the other way to do it is to
make a clues request we get it slightly
different we get the same information
back but in a different layout and here
we get a list of the individual clues
with their data and then we have a
category property to that clue that it
has the category information for better
for worse I chose this ladder structure
to work with because I was intending to
build a database
of clues that would have a property
being there categories so that was the
structure I wanted to use okay
so let's pull some data and work with it
and one of the first things I noticed
was that there are embedded HTML tags
they seem to be exclusively about
italics and and they would use that for
titles of books or songs or things like
that and I didn't want to leave these
raw HTML clues in there so I wrote a
function called embed um ballot embed
italics to convert the HTML tags into an
italic string basically turning it into
linear syntax so we can see doing that
now Johnny Belinda is written in italics
they're having the structure of nested
rules just begs for using associations
and so that's that's what we did
and but to do that we need to convert a
few of the left-hand sides of the rules
called the keys into a standard form so
they can be used more easily with
associations so anything with an
underscore you know an underscore in a
string is no problem but an underscore
and a wolfram expression means that it's
a pattern and the trying to you we
wanted to be able to use these keys in
functions that work on associations and
they're the string had to be without
underscores so we could use it as part
of the as the slot argument in the in
the anonymous function so we we can we
just camelcase them to make it easy and
then I wanted to make sure that the the
data we got back the JSON data met the
the structure that we needed to turn
everything cleanly into associations and
this function here make associations
does that so now I can take the query
and I have associations which makes it
much easier to work with in terms of
pulling two pieces out so I can get all
the keys for the Association and I can
easily get the title
okay or I can get the list of clues and
he's these are the keys for all the
clues so associations are just really
nice to work with and in the end we can
turn them into a data set okay so that's
doing everything there we also need to
check to make sure everything is good
because in one of our queries we can see
here that one of our values was null so
this database while it's pretty good
it's not necessarily well curated for
some reason on this one clue the value
of $300 was dropped and so what do we do
in that case you know do we try to fix
it or do we move on in this case I chose
will move on there's so many sets of
categories available I could easily
choose another category and you know get
it done you get the game built so both
forms there I wasn't good so here's a
good set of clues and we can test and
make sure it just everything is fine so
so we're good there okay so I chose five
categories to build my game and it looks
like they might be a little bit random
but they're not so let's pull the data
okay I just pull the data down from the
web I've got five categories each with
five clues these are the categories pair
of dice lost little women story time
dancers and drinks and you know you know
that they often have puns in their
categories in terms of things from the
in the real game and that's what we're
seeing here and yes they're all usable
so let's turn it into a data set and
here's a little bit of what it looks
like so we've got the the values we've
got the questions we've got the answers
we've got the category title and so on
okay so let's build the game board so we
would pull out the categories
we'll get the values and you know we
need to lay them out in a grid so I'm
just showing them that way here all the
questions laid out and the answers and
we can mock it up pretty easily so I'm
just using a flip view which is a
convenient way of just clicking on an
expression and getting the next one in
the queue and then you just keep cycling
so initially we would see the categories
at the top and the values and then we
would see questions and then we'd see
answers and then we would go back to the
full game board with the values to
choose the next one so this is the
general layout that we want to use as I
mentioned earlier we have to worry about
the event and the the process of the
game is you know the contestant picks
one of the cells and the question gets
revealed the answer it or not the score
gets incremented if they got it right
and then you go back again to do that
over and so here it is the flow of
things and once they've answered a
question that cell is now blanked and we
shouldn't be able to click on it again
so that it stays here in this blank
State
okay so button is our workhorse here the
basic structure of a button is a label
and some action that is taken when it's
clicked and so what we're going to do is
make the label of the button be dynamic
based on the current state of the
gameplay and so it will show either the
value it will show the question it will
show the answer or it will be blank and
so here's just a quick test so here it
is with the value we click on it we now
have the question we click again we get
the answer and we click again it's blank
and now it is I'm clicking and it's not
doing anything because I have disabled
the button in that final state so we can
put it all together into a board we get
the we give it the data the data set
our clues we pull out the the category
ID is the categories the values the
questions and the answers I'm selecting
from my data set with the data set
select features and I'm using outer to
build up the array to make sure that I
get everything in the right order I get
all the questions the clues for a given
category in that column all the clues
for a given value in that row I'm not
counting on the structure of the data
coming in to be exactly the way I want
it so I'm driving it completely
internally I define a function here to
reveal the questions and the answers in
the full screen I'm defining a function
here to build the game board itself and
then I instantiate the game board and we
get to play so let's define our game
play function and let's just do it once
and so here is our basic game board I
chose my four favorite contestants Bob
Carol Ted and Alice if you remember
there was a movie back in the 70s with
that title I see somebody does that's
great
okay I like it better than Tom Dick and
Harry that's too sexist but anyhow so we
can pick drinks for 200 the children's
cocktail is ginger ale and grenadine
garnished with a maraschino cherry so
what is that it's a Shirley Temple okay
Bob got it right so he gets two hundred
dollars and we click again and we go
back to the game board it's now blank
and we can pick another one okay this is
kind of bland so let's make some
improvements we can improve the font
make them bigger make them bold so
they're easier to read and we can do it
then add some color to it and now we've
got a background color I've colored the
contestants differently for contrast and
we can even add sound effects so I
pulled a nice sound off the web
so that when I reveal it are we get the
little more excitement for the game and
so now when I asked about it and I can
reveal the answer then with a little bit
of sound okay we can also take the data
from a spreadsheet and I've had to do
that more than once and sweet has kindly
provided me a set of clues okay
it was a two tabs on the spreadsheet six
rows and six columns because we've got
headings I can pull out five categories
and 5 sets of clues each it is indeed
usable Thank You Swede I did fix a few
typos and let's turn it into a data set
and now we can play ok this should be
good ok the first time I played this
game I ended up with a VGA projector and
my nice big MacBook Pro screen went down
to 680 by 4 20 or something like that
and nothing fit so I've had to deal with
a number of different resolutions so
here is our game and do we have some
contestants please
okay names
okay we just barely fit okay mark you go
first 300 this function provides
detailed data on all standard map
projections not quite okay Ashley
returns an image captured from a
connected camera yeah okay and you are
in first in Marcus in second so where
are the tweaks I added was actually
keeping track of who's who's where
because when you're playing with eight
tables of teenagers and it gets really
raucous in the room I can't read all the
scores and sort them out in my head so I
let Mathematica do it for me so anyway
I'm out of time but you know we've got a
wonderful game we can play with you can
give it your own categories if you're a
teacher you can use it in the classroom
you know if you're a church you can use
it with a youth group if you're at a
conference you can use it with your
friends you can even use it with your
own family if you want on a rainy
Saturday night you can pull stuff down
from the web there are a number of
things I'd like to do
well I there's a whole bunch of stuff I
learned along the way you know a lot of
people like to do top-down design which
is called waterfall I like to do
incremental design which is called scrum
I find it much much better there's a lot
of room for improvement
adding the Daily Double players we'd
like to have an interface where you can
look at all the categories and pick
categories in real-time and then play
the game and mistakes happen so having
an undo feature sometimes I've clicked
on the wrong contestant to award the
score boy did I get help for that and
things like that so you know there's a
lot more to do and like I said this took
me about a weekend to do that for the
first cut I've tweaked it you know over
the past couple of years since I first
built it so there's been some more
effort especially dealing with the
screen size stuff presenter tools should
make that problem go away crossing my
fingers so that's it I've got a minute
and a half for questions yes it will be
on the conference website all the
is here in the initialization section
it's all there okay thank you everybody
[Applause]